Dear citizens yesterday we met with 8 representatives of
the ancestral authorities in breach of my commitment to them.
Today,
the corresponding letters have been sent to the judicial body,
the Public Prosecutor's Office and the Constitutional Court.
In order for you to receive it and listen to what you have to tell them,
I call on you to peacefully abide by the provision of the
constitutional court on the limitations of the right to demonstrate,
since the blockades violate other rights in terms of health,
education,
free locomotion but especially because they threaten the lives of citizens.
of the protesters respect what the constitutional court decided.
I am extremely concerned about food shortages that threaten life,
ambulances that run out of fuel threaten life,
and the consequences of their actions threaten life.
We continue to bet on dialogue to find a way out and we ask that they be
respected in such a way that the constitutional court ruled why they can
demonstrate without causing the slightest harm to the population in general.
We have learned of the seriousness of the water shortage in the capital city.
We ask those who have closed their
shaiapishkaya keys to open them to supply the capital city.
Otherwise,
Guatemala could run out of water or enter a period of reasoning We
understand that we have been notified that the municipality of Guatemala
filed a criminal complaint for the seizure of the dam We are awaiting the
judge's resolution we have fully identified those responsible we have
complied with the provisions of the Constitutional Court to achieve the
unblocking of important roads and routes in the
country by the National Civil Police,
who has followed all protocols and we even thank
the demonstrators who have peacefully withdrawn.
At the moment,
4 trucks are being held in the trap sector in Sololá,
with hemodialysis products for patients in the west of
the country who are demanding them for life and death.
The lack of water in the city affects centers that care for kidney patients,
not only the equipment needs water for this to be effective,
without which these Guatemalans run the risk of losing their lives.
There are 5 lics hospitals that face serious and
dangerous difficulties when running out of water.
These are the general hospital Dr. Juan José Arévalo Bermejo,
the general hospital of diseases,
the comprehensive care center for pensioners of Barranquilla,
the external specialty consultation unit
in Gerona and the polyclinic of zone one.
The gentlemen who have taken over the facilities of
the pixcaya city will be responsible if any death occurs.
As a result of this we ask you to please lift this blockade,
the corresponding complaints have already been
sent and we have them fully identified again.
On the other hand,
it is clear to me that the President of the Republic cannot directly
remove the Chief Attorney General of the Public Prosecutor's Office,
as demonstrated at yesterday's meeting.
This means that the current regulatory framework makes
compliance unfeasible for the President of the Republic.
President of the Republic,
as head of state and higher authority of the executive body,
must be carried out in strict compliance with the principle of legality.
For this reason,
in the exercise of my functions as President of the Republic,
he has been delegated to me by mandate from the people,
in accordance with Article 182 of the Political Constitution of the Republic,
and his actions must be marked to the limits established by the legal system.
In this sense,
Article 152 of the Political Constitution of the Republic of
Guatemala is clear that the exercise of public power is subject
to the limitations indicated by this Constitution and by the laws,
which is why it is important to cite Article 14 of
the Organic Law of the Public Ministry Decree 40 94,
which was reformed through Article 6 of Decree Number 18 2 016,
which establishes and I quote it verbatim.
Article 14 removal,
The President of the Republic may remove the Attorney
General of the Republic by duly established justified cause,
justified cause shall mean the commission of a
intentional crime during the exercise of his function,
provided that there is a duly enforceabley.
That law was not put by us,
that law was put in the time of the Sisi to protect Mrs. Telmaldana.
Today they want me to execute as I was before and it is not possible to simply
and I simply cannot do it and it is by asking for it or trying to do it that I
am committing a crime called overreaching
my functions and an abuse of authority.
Dear citizens,
the Rusber hospitals,
St.
John of God and dozens of private
hospitals run the risk of running out of water.
But most of all,
think about it,
even the people who have studied them are going to run out of water.
I ask you to please order the people who have
taken the Shaya Peshkaya aqueduct to cross it,
otherwise we will wait for the judge's order and we will
have to obey the order of We want to keep the peace but
we will also be able to act in accordance with the law.
We are just waiting for the order of the competent judge to be able to proceed.
Let us not reach these extremes,
forget the water of the city.
The people will be eternally grateful to you and you will count
on the favor of many of the people who today look at you as
someone who is repressing you and the people who are repressing you.
is repressing their rights Let's apply what the constitutional court
said in Regarding the right to demonstrate and the limitations it has,
let's restrict the roads 50 by 100 of them at least so that there can be
traffic There are 4 lanes Let's press two If there are two lanes Let's
press one but let the traffic flow in both directions We cannot continue
to stop the country The damage that has been done to the country is
irreversible and today we have to recover We came out of a pandemic We
can well come out of this and recover economically in the next three months,
but it is up to you.
We will continue with the dialogue and continue to promote it,
but above all we also need the counterparty to
show its good faith and do what is due to it,
to know the water of the capital city as a demonstration
of good faith and for the dialogue that has already begun.
in the judicial body
God bless you but especially God bless Guatemala.